now who are these guys are your
bodyguards no we'll holla's uh he's part
of my security team and uh Burns is uh
my road manager you guys are part of
what they call an Entourage or what you
can say that crew what's it like do you
have to live in the shadow of this man
or uh can you can you get your own
identity going
well Hollis identified everybody know
holla everybody know Burns you know
right right but you're the head guy
I'm I'm the guy that gets on the stage
so you got to pay everybody too big
responsibility it's a little bit of
responsibility now will you guys beat
anyone's ass who comes into contact with
Ja Rule who tries to start something is
that uh that would be your job
do you know karate at all karate
want to see my head of security Ronnie
come on in here my head of security is
like a 60 year old guy and I'm thinking
what could he do against him
Sopranos 60 year old guys are dangerous
look at him he looks like he's whacked
somebody this morning
I've seen his work let me see you kick
his ass right now
that's not part of being security he
doesn't want to fight unless he has to
what if ja rules had a security came
over here and started beating my ass
what would you do do whatever I had to
do what would you do
I can't get him away from you you would
yeah but what could you do he'd call
yeah okay Ronnie would jump on and hit
me
have you ever had to beat up somebody
for Ja Rule like you know like like uh
handle a situation just prevent it I try
to not do all that I just prevent that
from happening yeah but did you ever
have to give a physical with someone and
mix it up a little
not really really it's just crowd
control yeah just crowd control you know
I'm saying keep everybody away but as
you can tell he has a loud big voice
yeah you'll carrying everybody back can
you carry some mace with you or
something make some people down or you
don't even need anything I don't even
need that right you're just a physically
intimidating man how much you weigh
like 320 320. and how tall are you six
five Ronnie how tall are you five eight
and a half
what do you weigh about 175. you must
feel very secure yeah I'm feeling real
good